today we were planning on doing one of
our voter voices segments but instead
I'd like to take a moment to assure
everyone that killer clowns are not real
they are a manifestation of our anxiety
people are super freaked out by the
election some goobers are taking that
anxiety and they're just bringing into
the real world they're trolling us all
and in a way aren't they kind of holding
up a mirror to society and reflecting
where we're at right now this sort of
grotesque painted figure that's darker
than it seems beneath the surface but I
promise you there is no such thing as a
murder clown your real love murder
first of all I think white face is wrong
and you're you're not gonna kill us are
you
probably not hey you want to smell my
flower no it's full of human blood all
right why why are you here Oh Chris
because this election is very important
and I just want to make sure our voices
are heard now I'm not here only on
behalf of murder clowns okay I'm also
here for thieving magicians loitering
acrobats jugglers that are cannibalistic
and Scientologist okay
don't count okay so I assumed because
you're a violent psychopath trying to
sow chaos you're voting for Trump oh no
way man he scares the out of me the
paint on my face may be rendered from
the human fat and kidney blood of my
victims but I'm not crazy no no I am
with her all right that's why we're
popping up everywhere lately to get out
the road just look at this map of clowns
being seen from atlas obscura huh we got
Florida Ohio Pennsylvania swing states
huh but also we clowns feel comfortable
there because they remind us of hell
well okay okay this is shedding a lot of
light on this so the murder clown thing
is all about voting but why are you
luring kids into the woods
it's called grassroots campaigning Chris
you lure a kid into the woods
tie them up wave around a chainsaw boom
another vote for Hillary
oh hang on no what about this footage of
a clown going up to some random person's
door Oh
brandishing a machete okay door-to-door
canvassing Chris come on you knock on
the door you break in you hide in the
Attic for fifteen years coming out only
at night staring over the children while
they sleep and breathing in their breath
boom another vote for Hillary yeah okay
I get it okay I guess so
then I guess this footage of a clown
chasing joggers through a park was just
about getting him to vote oh no actually
we murdered the out of those guys
everyone needs to get out there and vote
Hey as scary as we are we're no where
near as bad as Donald Trump okay a
murder clown would be saying this but
please don't vote for the psychopath who
has fake hair in an orange face please
all right giggles the clown everyone
shego